one witness is having a hard time
grappling with a completely random
shooting at a gas station in the
southwest valley that left one man dead
that eyewitness tells us he felt
helpless as he tried to save the victim
he spoke exclusively with our victoria
saha she joins us in the studio tonight
with more victoria
this witness made it clear to me he does
not want to be identified to glorify his
actions because he believes he was just
being a human being that wanted to help
he is bothered by the fact that the
victim 35 35-year-old curtis abraham
didn't make it
this man works the graveyard shift at
sporting life bar it's right next to the
gas station on jones and rainbow where
the alleged shooter 22-year-old jesus
uribe walked into the parking lot just
after midnight thursday wearing a
bulletproof vest police say he shot at
an empty car then walked over to curtis
abraham's car and shot him to death next
he went inside the gas station and
started shooting at customers as they
ran for their lives the gentleman that
was at the gas station that ran into the
bar saying that someone was shooting at
the gas station he ran over to help
despite not knowing if the shooter was
still around he tells me at first he
wanted to make sure his friends at the
gas station were okay chips sodas and
things scattered all over the place he
then came across curtis abraham's car i
seen him leaning sitting back in the
vehicle leaning back in the car the mute
the car was still on the music was loud
he says he immediately took off his
shirt and started applying pressure to
abraham's gunshot wounds i was just
trying to keep him in weight keep him
conscious
tell him stay with me stay with me the
ambulance is on this way i can hear the
ambulance abraham was pronounced dead at
the hospital but this man wants his
family to know he did his best to save
him i apologize that i
that i myself wasn't able to do more but
i did what i hope that any human
would have done for any of us police say
this was a completely random shooting
uribe was arrested after more than a
12-hour manhunt
the man tells me the situation could
have been a lot worse if a rebate walked
into the bar that night because it was
packed as for uribe he refused to face
the judge yesterday he faces multiple
charges including murder and three
counts of attempted murder sasha